hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is nfc explained so what is nfc well nfc
first of all stands for near field
communication and it's a technology that
allows you to transfer small amounts of
data between two nfc enabled devices
which we'll get to in a second and to be
honest you actually don't have to touch
the devices together it's near field
which means you can get usually within
about a centimeter of the devices and
they will successfully transfer the data
and there are a lot of really practical
applications for it there are also a lot
of nfc enabled devices already out there
you might be watching this on one right
now and i'll have the link to those down
below the like button on this video if
you have an nfc enabled phone it'll be
built into the back usually into the
battery cover or into the battery itself
so the back of the phone is where you'll
find the nfc chip in your nfc enabled
devices this is an nfc tag and inside of
it is a small thin microchip that can
hold a certain amount of bytes of
information which varies per chip but
every nfc command that you write to one
of these takes a small number of bytes
maybe three to five bytes per command so
you can hold multiple commands per card
so each one of these can hold a couple
of commands and you can even have it
tell one device to do one thing but when
another device touches it it'll tell
that device to do another thing so you
can have strings of commands on here
it's a really versatile device for just
a small little microchip inside of a
little plastic shell so you can use an
application like nfc task launcher on
android or nfc interactor on windows
phone and i'm sure when the iphone
finally has nfc there will be an app for
that too but these apps will let you
read and write commands from and to the
nfc tag and so let's go ahead and do
this one for example let's go ahead and
make this the tag that i tap every time
i leave the house to walk to class so
i'm going to program this red tag here
and the link to the android app i'm
using is down below but basically what
i'm going to do is create a new task
make it an nfc task and then add the
actions that i want to be associated
with that task and this is the whole
list of all the things i can do to make
this phone change or what i wanted to do
when it taps the nfc tag so you can see
it's a pretty awesome list so when i
leave the house i want to track the
sound all the way up i also want to
maximize the screen brightness and i
also want to disable wi-fi since i'll be
hopping onto a 4g network so but this is
basically the huge list of all the
things you can see there's tasker
integration a whole bunch of different
system settings but i'll go ahead and
crank wi-fi off hit next and then i'll
make sure all the toggles are set to
what i want it to do so when i tap it i
want it to disable wi-fi i want it to
enable the vibrate mode for sound and
crank the screen brightness to 100 when
i walk outside once you've picked
everything this is what the tag is going
to do go ahead and save and write and
swipe the tag onto the back of the phone
and as you can see it was written
successfully and we're done so there you
go now whenever i leave the house with
this guy in my back pocket i can
literally touch my phone to my butt and
it'll do all these commands that i
already programmed it to do and that's
it you're set i'm set to go so clearly
nfc is awesome so without any further
ado throwing at you with a quick top
five i know you didn't think this was a
top five video but let's go ahead and
take a look at the top five awesome
things that nfc can do number five app
launching let's say i stick one of these
in my car dock i can have it launch
google maps when i put my phone in it
that simple brilliant number four at the
bedside and i actually use this one
whenever i tap my phone to the nfc
sticker next to my bedside it dims the
screen silences the phone and sets an
alarm for the next morning that i have
already predetermined number three is
business cards now clearly paper
business cards the traditional type
aren't really going anywhere anytime
soon and we've seen people attempt to
put qr codes on the back i don't really
like those but an nfc enabled business
card that takes the swiper right to your
online resume or your website would be
pretty sick number two boarding passes
and transit tickets obviously there are
a whole bunch of different things that
are awful about the system at least in
the united states for boarding passes
and transit tickets and getting paper
and getting onto the transit that you
need to get on so having just the
ability to swipe your phone and board
the plane or swipe your phone and get on
the train without having to worry about
that is uh definitely something we'd be
looking forward to number one mobile
wallet having your phone
be your wallet in your pocket without
having to carry a whole bunch of cash or
coins is awesome now swiping your phone
to pay at a mcdonald's or a dunkin
donuts can either make you look like a
complete idiot or a complete boss
depending on whether it works or not but
when it does work like it did for me at
a 7-eleven a couple of weeks ago you see
that little google wallet logo you swipe
to pay and you start walking out the
store you automatically blow the mind of
anyone who is in that store at that
moment sometimes they don't actually
realize that you just paid and they
start to stop you like hey why are you
walking out the store right now and then
you look back and it's processed the
payment is done it came from your google
wallet account and speaking of google
wallet google wallet is basically on the
forefront of pushing this technology
basically the mobile wallet stuff to be
in the forefront and that's why google's
doing work right now so those are your
top five honorable mentions go to
parking meters those would be cool nfc
enabled parking meters so you could just
pay with your phone because no one likes
carrying coins around they're incredibly
cumbersome and just terrible another
honorable mention goes to android beam
because that's pretty much the easiest
and most efficient way to share files at
least small ones between devices so if i
want to share my file with you i don't
want to have to upload it somewhere for
you to download it somewhere or email it
to you or text it to you that all just
is an extra step i don't want to have to
take here let me just give you the file
tap the backs of your phones together
and uh android beam takes great care of
that ever since android 4.1 i believe
that's a new feature so every android
phone with android 4.1 or above has
android beam enabled so if it has nfc
just tap the back and send a picture or
video whatever and another honorable
mention goes to car keys because how
awesome would it be to just walk up to
your car pound it and the door unlocks
that'd be sweet obviously it wouldn't be
the most convenient thing in the world
because say you're in a rush and you
just miss that exact right spot but who
cares that's awesome so clearly i love
nfc i think it's a pretty underrated
technology and i've recently started
using it more because i've found all the
awesome things that it can do really
enticing so i'm getting more back into
it i have a lot of nfc tags and i
definitely want to get more ideas from
them so definitely let me know what are
you guys using nfc for personally i'm
really just starting off with like you
know leaving a house with an nfc tag or
having it by the bedside but let me know
what you guys use and i'm sure you're
watching this on an nfc enabled device
so go out and try to pay for something
crazy with your phone see what happens
or or don't either way thanks for
watching and i will talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
so
you